new dawn wants to step into the ring
with us they got our recruitment video
killed on all the big social media sites
and threatened to sue anyone who hosts
it this is gonna cost us a lot of
followers dmca takedown 9 this is worse
than annoying this is a declaration of
war I will not be censored a new Don's a
[ __ ] scam rich people throwing away
their money for some elitist circlejerk
[ __ ] this could be big for us I mean
nobody's gonna take the side of those
[ __ ] unless they're already members
we are still gonna call this fake-ass
church what's corn hole where the corn
goes after you eat the Queen Josh Oh
they don't like us using footage of
their celebrity [ __ ] Jimmy siska so
let's start with him these are
highest-profile spokesperson thanks it's
Jimmy siska I mean when I was a kid I
had the cisco glasses the popped collar
I I even knew every line to open wounds
yeah me too I even have the lunchbox Shh
nice since dish nice just not nice
escape case anything about him there's
nice there's got to be another way all
right I don't
he's in town shooting cyber driver I was
just thinking maybe we could talk to him
[ __ ] up his relationship with new dawn
you can go back to being less of a
douche bag then I could go back to
wearing my sis cooties without feeling
like one wait a minute you used corn
hole as a verb that doesn't even make
sense in the context of you ok ok we
focus on Cisco mm-hmm new Don keeps
blackmail records of their celebrity
shills right we check out the local
center we just need to get in and dig up
his file everybody in
and I'll round up the locals and he'll
meet you there but the cornholing begin
yeah you heard the man cornhole for too
long predators have victimized the weak
and wounded under the guise of religion
the Church of the new God is asked as
yeah ranking the church is based on
financial contribution loyalty is bought
through blackmail and figure they
believe they are untouchable to do all
that will soon change that sack will
reveal the secrets and true purpose of
you're done you can help take up a mass
and protest your local recruitment
center let their leaders know what you
think of them online join us as we send
them a message this is no more dance
that we didn't get richer do what you do
the only cost you like saving
distracting enough feel you're gonna go
inside and take a peek or okay oh and I
wore my church clothes by enlightenment
it only cost your life savings
alright i'm heading in i'll dig up what
I can on Cisco we're about to go to
battle with these [ __ ] I need
anything shady you can find if we want
to pick up followers we need to generate
some serious outrage can't we just make
something up if we get caught lying
everything else dead sack ever claim
will be called a lot don't worry if
they've [ __ ] the bed I'll find the dirty
sheets and incomes Marcus with the
classy metaphor I aim to please
not worth the head I have a friend who
dated him for a couple she's given me
some insider info is he she says he's
super insecure like hi
confident
oh good lord
Oh
hey
guys I think we can use siska as an ally
the man's in big trouble with the church
they even planning an emergency audit
audit there after his money of course
they are but this is something different
they wire themselves after these
[ __ ] ela trying to do hickies and
play psychiatrist with each other it's
cute Sisk is waiting for the audit of
the show but he's gonna give me instead
are you serious you're gonna wing it so
gonna wing it first I have to delay the
real art he's gonna get a call from Jim
and Cisco yes guys you have to hear his
Jesus compression it's ridiculous hey
don't have time now I'll be in touch
hello Jason I heard you're coming for an
audit today Jimmy right right I was just
about to leave how's it going not good I
think I ate one too many empanadas my
friend my stomach is way too unstable
for recession
catch my drift yeah yeah I get you
violent violent die yes I understand can
we reschedule yeah we're gonna have to I
took a handful of chewables I'll give
you a call back soon I promise we're
good we're cool you take care of
yourself Jimmy working on
ah